So, let's define a mathematical framework
for how to deal with this. We define Skew(k)
as simply #G -- #C in the first k nucleotides
of the genome.
And the skew diagram is simply a plot showing
Skew(k) against k.
Now, let's construct the skew diagram for
the E. coli genome.
It looks beautiful.
Where do you think the origin of replication
in E. coli is, something we almost had no
hope to find.
Of course, it is at the point where it [the
skew] was decreasing and suddenly starts increasing,
which is here. We found the replication origin
in E. coli.
And now, lets try to find frequent words in
this origin, and hopefully, we will find DnaA
box in this frame.
After we run our Frequent Words Problem, unfortunately,
it turns out there are no frequent words that
appear even 3 times in this replication origin,
which means that we failed.
There are many reasons why we may fail: maybe
the origin of replication, as derived from
skew diagram, does not show precisely the
area we want to see.
Or maybe, just maybe, we don't have a good
grip on what hidden messages in E. coli origin
look like.
Should we give up? Let's try to proceed further
and figure out what else can be done.
When we were looking for frequent words, our
view of frequent words was very naïve.
We assume that frequent words are simply k-mers.
But maybe hidden messages that the cell uses
to initiate replication are more elusive,
more subtle.
Let's look at this origin of replication in
Vibrio cholerae and try to see, maybe there
is something else.
We already found six 9-mers in this region,
but maybe, just maybe, there is something
else that deserves our attention.
[If] you look carefully there, then you will
see that in addition to these six hidden messages,
there are two more.
There are actually two 9-mers that look almost
like canonical 9-mers, they differ just in
a single mutation.
And they also represent DnaA boxes because
DNA can bind not only to the perfect 9-mer
but to different variations of this 9-mer.
So, to find this type of more elusive frequent
word, we need to solve Frequent Words with
Mismatches Problem when the input is a string
Text and integers k and d, and you want to
find all most frequent word k-mers with at
most d mismatches in Text.
And finally, after we have done this, and
run our Frequent Words with Mismatches Problem,
we do find somewhat more elusive frequent
words in E. coli genome, and they turn out
to be real DnaA boxes in E. coli.
Now, what I described is a very idealistic
view of how the origin of replication can
be found.
In reality, some bacteria have fewer DnaA
boxes, and our Frequent Words Problem will
not work for finding them.
The terminus of replication is often not located
directly opposite the terminus of replication,
and the skew diagram is often more complex
than in the case of E. coli.